think you understand the big picture
that i have and i want you to just
respect that
okay
yeah
janelle brown is not happy with husband
cody brown's rules he acts like i'm not
doing anything
i wear a mask i sound so distance i
sanitize my hands i do all the things
that the cdc says to do but because i
don't follow all of his ten commandments
his rules i'm not following any rules
apparently
on sunday's episode of sister wives
while discussing plans for thanksgiving
with her partner and fellow sister wives
mary robin and christine janelle argues
with cody over his opinions on covet 19
precautions and quarantining which does
not allow their sons garrison and
gabriel to be part of their holiday
celebration no guilt trip just a little
prick to your conscience and you guys
decide what you do because i'm not going
to tell this family how they do it i am
going to lead the way that i think is
the right way
that's all i've got to say about that
i hope everybody enjoys their
thanksgiving but janelle insists cody is
trying to guilt-trip her this is
actually a plea as much as anything so
it sounded like it sounded like a guilt
trip like i hope you know that you're
jeopardizing all these people you don't
think i'm aware which leads her to say
this
janelle ultimately decides to ditch
thanksgiving with the fam but she wasn't
the only one we are going to go to aspen
mitch's for thanksgiving
but we will be here for christmas yep
that's christine telling the family that
she'll be spending the holidays with her
and cody's daughter aspen in utah but
this should come as no surprise the
mother of six recently ended her 25 year
spiritual union with cody which played
out on the tlc reality show mary i can't
do marriage with cody anymore i don't
want to
just look at the mountain i don't want
to do it anymore
my marriage to cody
is sad
well
this is just kind of the place that our
relationship is at and on november 2nd
christine and cody announced their split
on social media the 49 year old's desire
for independence has caused major
conflict and has been a central issue on
recent seasons of the show yeah i'm sure
everybody hates me all the time i'm
dealing with the stubbornest people i've
ever known we
don't have to do anything together it's
something e.t spoke to christine about
last year she opened up about why she
prefers living on her own instead of
everyone together under one roof i
really like living separate i like my
own space i like my own autonomy i feel
like i like me better now as and i just
feel like i've been able to
really
like raise my kids how i want to i
really have more of an independence and
i really i just
think the autonomy is really really nice
and i feel like as a person that i do
better with a little bit more distance
i'm sure that he would love to see
everybody more often but the quality is
really really really important and i
feel like we're getting a better
better conversations
closer conversations
than we used to